For the longest time I didn't like writing
business plans.
Here's why.
Because every time it came time to write a
business plan, it was almost as if my school
teacher from Jr. high school would say, "Patrick,
go do your homework.
Write up a business plan."
And I'm sitting here saying, wait a minute.
First of all, I don't know how to write a
business plan.
Secondly, I don't think it works.
I don't think it's effective.
I don't think this thing's going to work.
Until I realized how to write up a business
plan that worked for me and from there on,
I could not wait to write up my business plan
for the following year.
So today, we're going to talk about two different
types of business plans.
One, which is dissecting and spending six,
seven, eight hours getting every single detail
of your business plan in place, that you read
once a month.
Then from there, gathering all the information
and taking all the simple things, the clear
things that you need and creating a one-page
business plan.
And that's the one that you look at multiple
times per day.
So we're going to cover those two things today.
Now, prior to writing up a business plan for
2017, let me tell you what's even more important
than writing a business plan for 2017.
Many times we will go through a past relationship.
And the relationship didn't work.
And some of us guys, you know, we can't wait
to just say you know what, it didn't work.
And we move on and we go to a bar and meet
a new girl.
And we move on.
Then that girl doesn't work.
And then the next one.
And this one doesn't work.
And the next one.
And then this one.
Four years goes by.
And we say, "Wait a minute.
How come I don't have a steady relationship?
How come none of these things are working
out?"
Well, because every single time one of them
didn't work, you didn't ask yourself what
would you have done differently.
What could you have done differently?
What can you change about the next one?
Is there a trend that you keep picking up
on that you know is not effective and it's
not working for you?
We don't do this.
The same exact way why most people who write
business plans, all they're thinking about
is the next year, while the most important
data for you is the year that just passed
you by.
In order to predict the future, you've got
to study history.
This is history, 2016.
What happened in 2016 for you?
What went right?
And if you had a bad 2016, I gauge my year
based on what percentage of my goals that
I wrote down on a sheet of paper become a
reality.
If less than 50% of my goals become a reality,
it tells me something.
Here's what it tells me.
It tells me one, I didn't give the best effort
or urgency and number two, I didn't have the
best strategy in place.
So it's effort or strategy.
And by the way, most of the time it's number
one, effort.
Sometimes it strategy.
A lot of times people say, but you don't understand.
The market was bad, and there was this.
. . Great.
One percent of the time you're forgiven for
that.
99% of the time, I want to know what I can
control and I can control most of it.
So, we look at that past year.
And when I look at my past year, the way I
do business plan, a lot of times I used to
just look at my business.
It's only business I'm going to look at!
Because this is the only thing that matters.
Yes, that sounds kind of great, in a class
at business Wharton school or Harvard, but
in life everything's kind of connected.
So, imagine trying to grow your business while
you have a relationship that's just day and
night you're arguing with your girlfriend.
It's tough to drive your business if all you
do is argue all day on text.
So imagine you're about to get into a sales
presentation and your girl and you get into
a text fight.
Now try to go in and do the presentation for
a sale that's going to make you 20 grand properly.
So this is what we do, do you have any problems?
They don't want to do business with you because
they feel something's wrong with you.
Relationship.
So I started looking at my business with everything
that's connected to the business,.
Personal development, this is business [left]
this is personal life [right].
My financial issues makes me have a bad business
because I stress out if I don't have my finances
in order.
My personal family life, you know, kids if
you have kids.
Girlfriend, boyfriend, husband, wife, mom,
dad, sibling - that affects business if that's
not steady.
Health, you gain 40 pounds all of a sudden.
Your energy is lower.
You get tired earlier.
You know, you have certain pain that, throbbing,
or certain things.
That's effecting this [business].
You're getting a lot of headaches, and you
don't really know where the headaches are
coming from.
Maybe you need glasses.
Hello, PBD, I went last week, the doctor says
I need glasses and I'm getting glasses so
you're going to see me start doing episodes
with glasses, which I'm sure the first few
episodes are going to be hilarious.
Stay tuned.
My glasses are officially ready today.
I think I'm going to go pick them up some
time later on today.
Spiritual.
For some of you guys that are very spiritual,
is that connected to your business?
So, 2016, gauge every one of them.
How did you do in every one of them?
And this is how you do it.
Good, bad, ugly.
What was good about your financial, 2016?
What was good about it?
What was bad about it?
What was ugly about it?
What would you have done differently?
Did you work hard in 2016?
What are some details you can gather about
every one of these things?
A relationship didn't work.
Why not?
What was good about it?
What didn't work?
What part of it was on you, that you can control
and change?
Now I'm not talking about getting emotional
and putting I want to know what love is or
and then texting her back and saying, "Babe,
I miss you so much.
I wish.
. . " I'm not talking about your reminiscing
and going back to that.
I'm just saying what was different about it?
What can we do different with health?
Good, bad, ugly.
I ate too much.
I just started eating so much bread.
I ate so much sweets.
I became lethargic.
I only worked out two times a week, at best.
I don't even walk anymore.
I used to walk.
I'm not doing it any more.
Why not?
Right?
Spiritual, business, personal development.
So then as you're going through this and you're
dissecting everything about your business
for that, the following year, now you're looking
at '17, let's just say you found all your
mistakes, all the mistakes you made.
You said you were going to give up some things
and sacrifice, and you didn't.
You still watch a lot of T.V.
You said you would give up certain things
too, you didn't.
You're still.
. . these are trends.
This is what you need.
This is all the details you need.
This is what's going to help you have a great
'17.
This is the truth.
This stings.
This hurts.
This sucks.
This is not fun.
But if you can get through this, man, heaven's
around the corner for you in business.
If there's a heaven for business, it's around
the corner, but you've got to go through hell
first.
I'm telling you right now, you've got to go
through hell first.
So that part's first.
Now, let's just say you went through this.
Now you want to put a business over here.
Great.
For each of these categories, now, for 2017,
you've got to start writing things down.
For instance, financially.
In 2017 when it comes down to my finances,
I'm going to start saving $3,000 a month.
Hypothetically, I'm throwing a number out
there.
You know, one of my things I want to do financially
in 2017, I want to save $50,000.
I want to save $100,000.
I want to save $10,000.
I want to save a million dollars.
Ten million.
Whatever the number is, I want to do that.
Great.
I want to pick up these habits.
When it comes down to my family I want to
look for a girlfriend.
I want to find somebody steady.
I want to look for a boyfriend.
I remember in '08, no, '06, '07 - when I assessed
my 2006, and I was going into '07, I had to
ask a very weird question for myself.
Here was the question.
Do I even want to get married?
I saw a bunch of my friends getting married.
They were happy.
And some of them were miserable.
I saw all these stories about oh, you don't
want to have kids, man, let me tell you one
thing about kids.
You're going to stay up.
I wish they would have told me, bro, all this
stuff about kids are great.
People do it because everyone's doing it.
. . And I just studied it.
Do I want to have kids?
Do I want to have a family?
Then I made a decision.
I do want to have kids.
I do want to have a family.
I'm the only Bet-David left in our lineage
that can continue the family, I do want to
have family.
And I do want to continue this.
But here's the next part.
I have no clue exactly what I'm looking for.
So I went and studied.
I read a book, 101 Questions to Ask Before
You Get Engaged by Norman Wright.
And I went through all these 101 questions.
I got very clear on what I wanted.
I took that book.
I was dating four girls at that time.
I had each of them read the book.
Came back, three off, one made sense.
Those three are happily married, all of them.
They're happily married, they all have great
marriages, they're all good where they're
at, but we just weren't a fit for each other.
And I moved on and I found my wife and we
are married, we have three kids.
And we're still happy as of today.
We've been married for seven and a half years.
But I had to figure out what I wanted to do
with my family.
I can't just say, "Let's go 17!"
No, clarity.
You want clarity.
What do you want?
Clarity.
What are you looking for, right?
So family.
Health, spiritual, personal dev - what needs
to change?
Once you figure that part out, like let's
just say in business.
In business you may say, what do I need in
business?
I need better systems.
Great.
Who do I need?
I need seven great sales people this year.
I need one great sales leader, and I need
two phenomenal assistants, and I need one
operations person.
Great.
Write it down.
How much do you need this year to expand your
business?
I need to make around a million dollars this
year.
Okay, great.
Write it down.
That's what you need to make.
Great.
Then, how are you going to make a million
dollars.
Then you go break that down.
Then that's the part when you write that long
business plan.
So you need to create a mathematical formula.
If I do x times y plus z, I will make a million
dollars.
So then give yourself a formula to hit that
number.
That's the long business plan.
Long business plan that you write.
So your goals are here [business], how you
get it is a deep, written business plan that
you have, right?
Once you've done that, once you have done
that, and you've written the detailed business
plan, then, on one sheet of paper, one sheet
of paper, you laminate, the front, on one
sheet of paper, you write down, "2017" - you
can put the title whatever you want - The
Year of . . . Give it a title.
Every year is a new campaign.
What is 2017 known for you?
What is your life, 2017 like.
Right here [title], one of my favorite ones
is 2017: The Year of Recreating Myself!
The year of recreating myself.
I think that's a phenomenal way to start off
for anybody, but yours may be the year of
explosion, the year of growth, the year of
expansion, the year of you know, whatever
it is.
You figure out a word.
But your year, you need to give it a title.
What is 2017 going to represent to you?
This gets a lot more fun as you keep continuing
doing it.
2017: The Year of.
. . Great.
Then on one sheet of paper, all of these six
brackets that you have, each one of them have
two things written on them.
Obviously, when it's a sheet of paper it's
more room, I'm just writing on the board here.
On one side, it's three new habits you want
to instill in this part of your life.
Three new habits.
For instance, financial, let me give you an
idea.
In '02, I created a habit of running my credit
score every single month, once a month.
I remember even on what day it was.
It was the 19th.
Every month, I ran my report.
That's a new habit.
Second, I tracked every single one of my financial
accounts on the 19th of every single month.
Mutual funds, stocks, investments, bonds,
artifacts, whatever I had, every single month
was my financial statement.
So these are new habits.
Then the next one is goals.
Habits, goals.
Three.
No more than three.
Three is enough for your brain to remember
this.
Three new habits, three new goals.
Family.
Three new habits.
You got kids.
Sunday's I'm going to do . . . with my kids.
Great.
You know, you got family.
I'm going to visit my parents once a month.
They live somewhere else that's two hours
away.
Whatever it is to you.
Habits, goals.
I want to find a steady boyfriend or a girlfriend.
Goals, not this year, next year we want to
have kids.
Goals, I want to strengthen my relationship
with my father.
Whatever.
Goals.
Habits, goals.
Same with health.
Habits, work out three times a week.
Habits, don't eat bread, all year long, except
for Sundays.
No sweets, all year long, except for Sundays.
Look at what will happen to your life.
Health.
So that's habits.
Goals.
Goals could be 190 pounds, 13% body fat, bench
press 300 pounds.
Goals, run a 26-mile marathon.
Okay, one of my friends recently, where did
he run it?
George ran a 26.2 mile marathon, I think he
ran it in Bakersfield, right?
He said he's going to run it, he ran it.
This is a guy I've been mentoring for the
last 12 years.
So he said, "I'm going to run it" and he ran
it.
It's very strong mentally.
So you put goals.
I'm going to run a marathon.
Go run it.
I'm going to bench press two plates, 20 times.
Go do it.
That's the goal.
For each side, personal development.
I want to read two books a month, four books
a month.
Okay, I want to read 50 books this year.
Great.
Personal development.
I want to find a new mentor.
That's a goal.
That is exactly the life I want to have.
I want to find a mentor.
You write it.
New habits.
what is a new habit?
A habit is you know, I am associating myself
with people that are better than me.
You can figure out the new habit that you
can put in.
I'm going to read 30 minutes a day.
New habit.
I'm going to have meditation, spiritual time,
30-minutes every morning.
Whatever it is for you.
Then business, same thing.
Three, three.
So habits, goals.
Habits, goals.
Now watch what happens.
When there's three habits, three goals.
You have your detailed business plan, you
revisit once a month.
Because the detailed business plan is going
to show you how to get to 190 pounds.
How to get to 12% body fat.
How to do xyz amount of revenue this year.
How to have $100,000 in savings.
That's the how-to.
This is the goal.
But your brain needs to see the numbers and
then you can validate it with the formula
that you've written on a sheet of paper that
could be 10 pages, seven pages, but it needs
to be in front of your face.
So what this one sheeter does for you, you're
allowed to review it daily.
You're able to drive your initiatives, and
you, re-remind.
Review, boom.
Re-remind.
And it's in your face.
In your face.
How do you and I learn the lyrics to a song?
Re-remind, re-remind, re-remind, re-remind.
How do you and I know the words to a commercial,
you know the Dos Equis commercial?
You know, he's so this, that even his enemies
put them down as an emergency phone number,
whatever.
Re-remind, re-remind, re-remind.
They put it in our face so many times, re-remind
and they drove the initiative.
And they reviewed.
Let's adjust.
Let's drive the next initiative.
Re-remind, Dos Equis, review - same thing
you've got to do to your brain, and your heart.
Same thing you got to do.
So once you do this, one pager, then you got
to make some sacrifices.
So what are your sacrifices?
What are you going to give up this year?
What are you going to give up in 2017?What
are you willing to give up?
Show?
T.V.? Bar?
Beer?
Drinking?
Alcohol?
Smoking?
What are you going to give up?
What are you going to give up in 2017?
Because you know what you need to give up.
Everyone's got a vice.
What are you going to give up in 2017?
Sleeping in?
Because that's the effort, and the strategy.
And the more time you spend on the strategy,
the details, the better of a one-pager you
can write.
The better of a one-pager you can write and
you remind yourself the rest is history.
So, you may be asking, man, I wish I had this
format.
I got it for you.
Here's what I need you to do.
I need you to go to my website, PatrickBetDavid.com,
if you're watching this video on the website,
go to the bottom, we have the one-pager for
you, the PDF, you can download it on exactly
how to have your one-page business plan written
on a sheet of paper, that you can use yourself.
It will be formatted.
All you got to do is print it out, grab it,
laminate it.
Put it against your shower wall, every morning
you wake up, every night you go to sleep,
look at it and read it out loud.
Just look at it.
Look at it, look at it, look at it.
Look at it.
Review, drive, remind.
Every day.
You will be amazed within a week, two weeks,
three weeks how much of this is already internalized
in you.
You can't help yourself but be thinking about
it.
And somehow, some way, you start hitting it.
Remember effort, strategy.
We got the strategy.
If you put the time, here's a one-pager, then
it's reminder, drive, review, and eventually,
next year comes back up, 2017, and you're
going to look at your last year, how this
year went by, and you're going to say, "Oh
my gosh, I hit 80% of my goals.
This is so exciting.
I hit 80% of my goals."
And by the way, people ask me for book recommendations
with this, honestly, I will tell you the best
book recommendation I can give you on this,
this may sound like I'm self-promoting, but
I can't remember the last time I self-promoted
this book.
I will tell you, though, I highly recommend
reading this book I wrote called 25 Laws for
Doing the Impossible.
It's sold 150,000 copies, translated in five
different languages, I think now it's also
in Mandarin, six different languages that
you can find.
And one thing about this book, 25 Laws for
Doing the Impossible, I wrote out exactly
the formula I used to recreate me.
So I'm telling you pure experience how this
cat went from being a 1.8 GPA in high school
to somebody no one expected was going to do
anything, goes in the military, comes out,
becomes a salesman at Bally's, and gets into
business, struggles for two, three years,
four years, trying to figure this whole thing
out, then I recreated myself, then the rest
was history.
This book, the first 10 laws are all about
how to recreate yourself, then how to identify
your cause and how to go out there and make
history.
So you can have the link to the book, Paul,
let's make sure we put the link to the book
on the bottom as well, 25 Laws for Doing the
Impossible.
And last but not least, Paul, give me what
you got there to your left.
Oh my gosh.
Let's see that first, and then give me the
other one.
So this one here, the poor pillow has done
a very good job for us in 2016 and helped
us hit a goal.
Today we had a young cat that drove 30 miles
away, named Phillip came through to just give
us this new pillow.
And we haven't yet decided what's going to
be the new pillow.
We're going to choose a new pillow.
This is how the pillow goes.
Subscribe to Valuetainment.
I love this new pillow, Phillip.
It's a cool-looking pillow.
It's one of the top three right now that we're
looking at.
If you haven't sent your pillow, if you have
not sent your pillow, we will be deciding
for these by December 31, on what pillow will
be featured in our videos in 2017, to say,
subscribe to Valuetainment.
Because our goal in 2017 is to get to a million
subs, so if you haven't subscribed, please
do so.
Paul, give us a good catch.
If you have any questions, comments, thoughts,
about this video, comment on the bottom.
Take care everybody, bye bye.